alors les élèves l'objectif bien sûr
c'était finale peut-être faire un
produit parce que ça c'est ça rentre
dans le cadre des épis on doit faire une
production dont la production c'était
pour eux dans un premier temps faire des
fiches biographiques sur les poilus de
la guerre de 14 18 dans un deuxième
temps de rassembler toutes ces fiches
dans un livre qu'il a publié le livre
venu de sortir ce matin
vous en pensez quoi vous vous êtes fière
c'est ça travail qui dure déjà depuis
trois ans mois cet été j'ai passé
pratiquement deux mois et demi à faire
la mise en page un tour reprendre
vérifier je sais comme un produit qui
est vendu donc il faut une certaine
qualité
donc je me suis imposé ce travail de
vérification à partir d'autres documents
dont je disposais en particulier des
les actes d'état civil alors c'est sûr
c'est bon scientifiquement juste à ben
pour moi c'est important je veux dire
moi je m'intéresse beaucoup à l'espoir
local c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
j'ai déjà publié d'autres livres y
compris d'ailleurs on avait publié à
l'époque les livres sur fran sur la
vallée de l'argens
je veux dire c'est important aussi de
mettre des choses exactes comme ça ils
disent que justement par rapport à ça la
difficulté pour certains élèves c'est de
déchiffrer des écritures qui date d'il
ya cent ans
c'est également d'être confrontés à des
noms des prénoms dont ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de voir des noms de lieux qui
ne connaissent pas du tout donc c'est
pas toujours évident pour eux étaient
partantes dit partant c'est sûr que sur
une classe une classe il ya solution
partant ceux qui le sont moins et c'est
bon après c'est un projet de la classe
donc je n'ai pas le choix si on veut
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya des élèves qui
sont beaucoup plus impliqué que d'autres
vous en tant que professeur
documentaliste vous leur a démontré
qu'il fallait être extrêmement rigoureux
quand on traitait de l'histoire
l'histoire une forcément je veux dire
comportement des indications ne serait
ce que sur le nom le lieu de naissance
la date de naissance sur le parcours de
souk du soldat pendant la guerre il faut
être précis
on ne peut pas se contenter de choses
une serrano donc un objet de et
rigoureuse et rigoureuse ça c'est la vie
dans toute recherche il faut être
rigoureux
qu'est ce que vous pensez que ça leur a
apporté à ces jeunes qui ont aujourd'hui
15 ans ce que ça leur apporter
moi je peux enfin un moment donné je me
souviens bnf qui me disais mais pourquoi
on fait ça chez ceux là on les connaît
pas les connais pas je dis mais c'est
pas une histoire de ne pas connaître
pour moi c'est moi je parlerais pas de
devoirs je parlerais plutôt de respect
de la mémoire qui est moins scolaire un
devoir le sont ces derniers je parle
plutôt de respect de la mémoire des gens
qu'il ya cent ans on leur a pas demandé
leur avis sont partis au combat
ça pourrait être mon frère le plus âgé
le plus jeune des pour lui chez moi
raconte henri alleg dix sept ans et sept
mois
dix sept ans et 7 mois c'est-à-dire
quelques années de plus que ceux qui
sont ici vous collège
donc ça aurait pu être la leur frère ça
pouvait être un homme donc et vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure comment ils ont
répondu visiblement la leçon a bien été
retenue non j'espère je ne nie pas les
conditions dans les tranchées qui sont
difficiles il parle du nombre on parle
du fait que les soldats ont subi alors
justement par rapport au projet comme
c'était un épi le projet était aussi
associée à des professeurs de lettres
donc dans ce cadre elle est professeur
de lettres surtout étudié donc les
lettres des lettres de poilus des romans
des bandes dessinées qui faisait plus et
ajustement des conditions de vie des
poilus dans les tranchées et à l'armée
alors que nous on faisait plus à un côté
bon état civil parcours du soldat mais
sans rentrer dans le vécu n'est ce pas
en lettres ça leur permet justement
visiblement ils ont retenu comme elles
sont dit qu ici c'est un oui d'après
leurs propos il ya des choses quand même
plaisant choqué un espoir dépouille à sa
tête la bouille non sans une certaine
empathie visait de cjad vis-à-vis de ces
soldats morts pour la france
alors c'est sûr pour eux tous les
sondages qui ont été traitées sont des
soldats qui sont originaires de
pontarlier où des villages environnants
donc il ya une proximité et qui qui fait
que les cds forcément sont intéressés et
certains ont voulu faire le soldat qui
portait le nom de famille pour un cousin
et oies le consortium qu'ils ont été
touchés par l'histoire